[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing the weasleys more
specifically we're going to be
discussing facts about the weasleys that
people who have only seen the films
won't know are the weasleys the child
wealthy money poor family that were
introduced to right in the beginning of
the series as harry attempts to board
the hogwarts express at platform nine in
three quarters fussy but loving mrs
molly weasley is kicking her children
into gear in order to make sure they
make the train on time and harry just by
being close by is brought into her
gravitational pull as she gives the
children orders left and right however
what surely no one knew at this point
was just how close harry would become
with the friendly loving and quirky
red-headed family the weasleys
immediately make their mark in the story
as good people who have nothing but
harry's best interest in mind and this
fact stays true for the entire story as
harry came from a very broken
complicated home he spent countless
weeks at weasley family home and during
those times molly weasley took him in
like one of her own no questions asked
the immediate weasley family in its
entirety consists of fred george charlie
molly arthur ginny bill percy and of
course ron and i guess we should sort of
count harry as a kind of pseudo foster
child because of the prevalence of the
weasleys to the harry potter story we
get to know a lot of the characters
quite well we see them grow evolve and
change into strong independent people
but with that said the films certainly
don't give us the same amount of
information as the books there are a lot
of things about these lovable characters
some fan favorites that you simply will
have missed if you didn't read the books
and in today's video i'm going to be
sharing some of these facts we can't
expect the films to include everything
that would be unreasonable but would it
have really been such a big deal to give
us five hour extended editions of each
film well probably but a man can dream
without further ado here are seven facts
about the weasleys that only book
readers will know number seven percy the
traitor remember percy the problematic
weasley well as it turns out the
problematic nature of percy isn't ever
really properly addressed in the films
one moment he's leading new gryffindor
students to the gryffindor common room
and the next he's got his hands on harry
potter working on behalf of cornelius
fudge and the ministry so what happened
to percy how did a boy that came from
such a loving family who had a close
relationship with harry i might add turn
into this sniveling traitor how could he
work for fudge well as it turns out it's
actually revealed in the books how this
happens and it all starts with percy
having a falling out with his family
percy like fudge refused to believe that
voldemort had returned to power and so
he had trouble coping with his family
who were big harry and dumbledore
supporters percy was everything his
family wanted him to be smart driven
well-behaved but he took it too far they
mainly quarreled because he sided with
the ministry at a time when the ministry
was even more questionable than usual
fortunately however peace is made with
percy later on number six molly's
boggart a boggart is essentially the
manifestation of someone's deepest
darkest fears it is an amortal
shape-shifting non-being that transforms
itself into whatever you fear most no
one knows what a pocket looks like by
itself because it will transform as soon
as you encounter it when pockets aren't
scaring people they can usually be found
rusting around in confined spaces or
lurking around dark corners what the
films never reveal however is molly
weasley's boggart which harry witnesses
her trying to remove from number 12
grimmell place while trying to oust the
creature from the house she sees her
biggest fear in the bogat and that's the
death of everyone that she loves 5.
molly and ginny hated fleur at first it
might come as a surprise to you that
molly the loving nurturing caring mother
that she is actually hated fleur de la
cour at least for a time however most of
this stemmed from her love for her son
in the likely reality that she felt no
woman was good enough for him her
ingenious rationale for hating fleur was
a combination of fair and unfair reasons
first they judged her by her looks
immediately categorizing her to fit the
dumb blonde stereotype secondly flo was
a bit arrogant which robbed both ginny
and molly the wrong way next there is of
course the element of motherly love to
molly only a perfect woman would be
worthy of her bill and molly was still
under the impression that her
relationship to bill was largely
superficial and physical molly simply
didn't believe that fleur was good
enough for bill but that is primarily
because she overlooked all of fleur's
positive traits on the slightly less
grave side molly was also irked by first
taste for her favorite singer celestina
warbeck fortunately molly and ginny did
eventually realize the mistake of being
too harsh on fleur this came after fleur
demonstrated her loyalty to bill
following his debilitating injuries
inflicted at the hands of fenrir
greyback when fleur stayed with bill
after his appearance changed as a result
of his injuries it became clear that her
relationship with him wasn't just
superficial or physical they truly were
compatible she really did love him
number four percy and ron see fred die
fred weasley's death was arguably one of
the saddest moments in the story book
and film alike however the
representation of fred's death does
differ a little from book to film in the
films fred appears to die alone with
none of his loved ones around him in the
book however fred's demise is witnessed
by both ron and percy percy who fell out
with the family in a big way has just
patched things up with fred when boom a
blast sends them all flying the only one
who doesn't wake up from the fall
however is fred before we get to point
number three i just wanted to mention
that i've been uploading a lot on my
other channel mythology explained so if
you want a mythology fix go and check it
out link in the pinned comment three
charlie weasley makes an appearance
though charlie didn't make an appearance
in the films he does return to hogwarts
twice in the books the first was in the
philosopher's stone when he retrieved
norberta and the second was for the
battle of hogwarts where he fought
voldemort in the death eaters charlie
never married nor had children but got
to spend his time with his copious
siblings nieces and nephews being an
outdoorsy type with an affinity for
dragons charlie was more preoccupied
with his craft rather than pursuing
ladies 2. arthur and molly's love arthur
and molly the weasley parents are often
portrayed as well parents and we view
them primarily in this way but what we
have to remember is that arthur and
molly are also individuals they're their
own people and not just their children's
parents this means that they of course
have their own backstories in the books
we learn that the pair met each other at
hogwarts got up to all sorts of mischief
together on one occasion molly and
arthur decided to go for a late night
stroll on the hogwarts grounds apollyon
pringle the caretaker at the time ends
up catching arthur but not young molly
pruitt number one the unbreakable vow
when you think of unbreakable vows you
usually think of severus snape narcissa
malfoy draco malfoy and bellatrix
estrange however what film watchers
won't know is that another unbreakable
vowel is actually mentioned in the books
a vowel pertaining to the weasleys fred
and george weasley in their youth once
attempted to coerce a then five-year-old
ron into one it is said that fred and
george were ready to perform the vow
when their father arthur weasley caught
them the vow though not quite of the
same magnitude as the one engaged in by
narcissa and snape was still
questionable magic for young wizards to
be performing on your sibling no less
this is the only instant in which the
mild-mannered arthur weasley is said to
have gotten as angry as his wife molly
and that's it for this video did you
know all of these book facts about the
weasleys obviously there are more but i
felt these were definitely some of the
big ones share some of your favorites
down below if you enjoy the content
please like the video and subscribe to
the channel until next time remember it
does not do to dwell on dreams forget to
live
[Music]
you